listen to the reaction by the audience
of The View when they get the news that
Whoopi has Co and Joey bayar claims it's
back um as you can see whoopy is not
here she has
coid yes it's back it's back it's back
but she's on the men she's on the tail
end and she probably back this week but
sorry she's not here for those of you
who are looking forward to seeing her
it's back it never left it's emic like
they made a point of saying it was
endemic like it's here forever so is you
know I just feel like the culture war is
divided amongst people who seek out
information to challenge their views for
the most part not always and those who
desperately don't want their views
challenged at all and just want to be
told what to do the people watch The
View they just want to be told what to
do what to think what to feel just tell
me when to jump I don't know I want to
fit in it'll be easy and then everyone
else is like H let me figure it out for
myself